hey guys so as you can see from the
title we
have something to talk about um
so you know that medical emergency i
keep talking about
that happened in april so it was this
which which is uh the fact that we had
a chemical pregnancy which is also known
as an early miscarriage
and it was really devastating
when it happened especially after such a
an emotional day that happened the day
before
the next day experiencing the
miscarriage um
it was just it was really rough
um but so we ended up like
i ended up finding out that i was
pregnant on april 8th
and it was super early still
um i had taken like one pregnancy test
and that that test was like super faint
to the point where like you could barely
see the line and then
every day for the next like few days i
started like i was just taking
a test like every single day trying to
see like wait am i really pregnant like
is this really happening
yeah we're trying for so long too yeah
well since like
i guess i guess like officially trying
was maybe like november
yeah october yeah i think like we're
trying like on and off like before that
yeah like really trying
since november we're so happy
we were so happy like so happy and
um and yeah and so like the
next days um i was taking a pregnancy
test and the line kept getting darker
and darker and darker and then finally i
told casey about it and that's when we
were really celebrating
and told isaac told our
family um and we're all just super
excited
and on april 21st is
when i had the miscarriage but the
previous day
um i was shooting big mood and
that's when um it was a very stressful
day
and that day i started spotting like
later on at night i started spotting and
then the next day
was when everything happened and so
what a chemical pregnancy is it's when
like it's an early
miscarriage which means it's like
shortly after implantation
so we only knew for like about two weeks
i was pregnant
so shortly after implantation it's when
um
something happens like it's it could be
unexplained it could be like
abnormalities or like chromosome
abnormalities or it could just be like
it wasn't
like a proper properly implanted or
millions of reasons
um what ends up happening is that like
my body
ended up passing that like
embryo was it an embryo yeah that embryo
as
as if it's like a period so then i just
ended up having like a really
heavy period and that's what a chemical
pregnancy is in case
you guys didn't know because i had no
idea what it was until it happened to me
i went to the doctor they measured my my
hormone levels
and that pregnancy hormone was like they
had me go in like a few days
and that pregnancy hormone was just
getting lower and lower which means
like yeah that the baby had
just passed astral yeah so
yeah and it took you a while to recover
from it too
yeah like like all these months like
like we haven't really been posting a
whole lot
and um and you know lots happened in the
last couple months too so
it's like it took a while for you to
kind of
come back come back to it yeah because
we actually we didn't even make it to
our first appointment
like that first ob appointment at the
six week mark
um didn't make it to that and we were
planning on
we were planning on telling you guys
like as soon as we finish telling
everyone all of our friends and
everything and
after that had happened um it just
was like oh man let me like
this is a lot like i had a lot going on
in that same week and
i just i kind of was in bed
like i couldn't i couldn't like function
it was just really i was really
depressed and
um yeah and so like it did take me a
long time
to finally like come to terms with it
process it you know going to therapy
about it
and you know working it out together and
like being there
for each other yeah and it definitely
brought us closer too
yeah how was it for you uh
yeah it was rough it was uh you know
it's
kind of traumatizing it's like it's so
like the whole
the whole pregnancy thing kind of is so
delicate you know i'm finding out
it's like anything can happen and like
the slightest bit of stress on you
is like could could end everything
so yeah it's kind of traumatizing it
took me a couple of days to like
really process it all um but i think
we're okay now
and you know i think we got we got
definitely got a lot closer i think we
spent a lot of time together you know um
just encouraging each other and actually
i want to say like during the pandemic
like we've been really focused on our
relationship too
yeah and i think i think before the
pandemic
like we've always wanted you know to
have a kid but
we like probably just weren't in a good
place yet in our relationship
yeah just a lot of things that had to
work out and i think the pandemic really
gave us an opportunity to
really just like have no distractions
and really work on a relationship
and um kind of iron it all out and so
in november i think we were like i think
we're good i think we're good and we're
in a better place and
let's do this baby thing um but yeah so
i guess we'll be trying soon but i i do
want to address
um i i find it so
infuriating sometimes when i read
certain comments about tiff
uh needing needing to give me a baby
like
like she is like supposed to give me a
baby
i yeah i don't know just that makes me
mad
because uh she doesn't need to give me a
baby you know if i'm not ready for it
we're not ready for it
and if we are we're trying you know and
like the pressure of needing to get
pregnant and all that stuff all these
years
it's like ever since we got married i
think like those comments just started
coming in and i was like when you guys
can have a baby i mean
i think there's there's there's a nice
way to ask it and there's like a very
i think entitled way of going about
yeah so um yeah because like
all this time and we've also been very
vocal like we
we do want to have kids like i do want
to have more kids and
i don't know yeah like getting those
comments throughout all these years and
and
people being just so cruel like
really cruel and saying that like wow
how how can like you know tiff have her
own kid
and have casey raise him but she won't
give
casey a baby of his own like it's just
it's really mind-blowing how some people
can like
just piece things and forget that we're
actual human beings
like we're not just characters on a tv
show or something that you can just
criticize like this but i do want to say
like i'm so like so grateful
to those of you that have like defended
us in the comments and have
placed these people in in their place
and said like hey you know back off like
you don't know what's going on behind
the scenes and
and so i just want to say like i really
appreciate you guys so much for having
our backs like that
it's it's not it hasn't gone unnoticed
and
it means a lot to me that you guys have
been so supportive
and have been so understanding you know
like we're
we're real like we actually are like we
have a marriage we have
a relationship we we are trying we're
we are doing our best and
yeah so so you know like like what casey
is saying the fact that
this whole pandemic like me personally
like especially we followed uh
me through other channels like i have
been
very vocal like i'm a very vocal kind of
person
like i i need to put my business out
there in order for me to kind of heal
from it and move on
um and that's why we talked about this
too and like until
casey was ready to talk about this
because it's also like his experience
that he went through
um and that's why now we're talking
about it because now we both feel like
we're in a good place to speak about it
but
not just about this experience but even
like throughout our entire marriage
you know i've been vocal about the fact
that like we have had our problems
and it really came out of the the
need to make sure that we're not being
misunderstood because at that time it
was
like oh you guys have a fairy tale
relationship you guys are perfect
and that scared me because i'm like oh
my god we are so not perfect
guys like let me tell you we're so not
like it really scared me to have
people um have this like fantasy of our
lives
expectation yeah of uh being perfect
yeah that was that was a lot of pressure
and and not just that but i felt like a
liar
like by not saying anything and not
being upfront about
certain things and so so now that like
you know we have
been working things out like so much to
the point where we were able to get
pregnant
um and you know throughout therapy
and throughout the whole pandemic like
we've really
worked on a lot of things we've grown a
lot we've matured a lot we've
learned to love each other a lot more
and really understand each other
and that's something that i also want to
put out there for you guys to know
like you guys heard the bad now you get
to hear the good you know
but yeah so i guess to answer your
questions we are
ready to have a baby and we are
trying we even cut out uh coffee and
like alcohol
and like yes like yeah alcohol and
caffeine we've
been off of that stuff and trying to
like cleanse their bodies because they
say like
yeah like they like like it's for guys
if you're drinking alcohol or drinking
too much caffeine same with women it
could uh limit your
sperm production same with women oh it
is okay
but yeah it definitely does like impact
your your fertility
so it does help to cut that stuff out
and so as soon as like you know we were
like
hunkering down we're like all right
we're ready let's do this we're at a
great place where now we can like
prioritize our intimacy
and you know like we can actually try to
make it happen
um yeah that's that's when we were just
like all right cut out alcohol
cut out caffeine exercise more often eat
healthier
drink more water yeah i'm going to try
more vitamins trying to get rid of my
pandemic body
and then my body got pretty bad at one
point it was like scrawny arms and
and like just flabby
yeah same i can definitely gain weight i
can see it in my face too i'm like way
more rounder
oh no yeah so we are trying we're
hopeful um and yeah i just really wanted
to
communicate this experience with you
guys
um because you know we consider you guys
part of the family
and always want to be transparent and
share whatever we can with you guys but
yeah that was the medical emergency that
i had that i keep bringing up
and saying that hold on i'm going to
talk about it i'm not ready to talk
about it
wait wait wait but yeah that's that's
what happened
but yeah uh thanks for hearing us out
and uh
yes we'll see you guys in the next video
you